[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Good morning, everyone.
It's great to see such a good
crowd at 9:00 in the morning.
It's going to be a great day.
Welcome to the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study.
I'm Liz Cohen.
I'm dean here at the
Radcliffe Institute.
And I am so pleased to welcome
you to today's conference,
Ways With Words-- Exploring
Language and Gender.
As an Institute
for Advanced Study,
the Radcliffe
Institute is dedicated
to inquiry that transcends
disciplinary boundaries
and to sharing the
fruits of that inquiry
with a broad public
audience through events
like this one and many others.
For example, this
year, we are partnering
with the Harvard
University Native American
Program on Native and Indigenous
Peoples Initiative, which
will culminate with
a conference entitled
Native Peoples, Native
Politics on Friday, April 29.
And I hope you'll
join us for that.
We also bring a wide
array of leading thinkers
and public intellectuals
to Radcliffe Yard,
such as our current Radcliffe
fellow, Michael Pollan,
the renown journalist best known
for his investigative reporting
on the food industry.
Pollan will be speaking
on Wednesday, April 6,
and I can promise you
a fascinating lecture.
We will conclude our programming
for the academic year
on Radcliffe Day,
Friday, May 27,
when we will award
the annual Radcliffe
medal to Janet Yellen, the
chair of the Federal Reserve.
That day will feature
an exceptional panel
on a topic that is very close
to Yellen's head and heart,
Building an Economy for
Prosperity and Equality.
The afternoon will
include remarks
from Ben Bernake,
Yellen's predecessor
as chair of the Fed,
followed by a conversation
between Yellen and
Harvard professor
of economics, Greg Mankiw.
And you can find
information on ticketing
through our Radcliffe website.
Video of all of the
events I've mentioned
will also be available
on our website.
Today we are gathered for
this year's major conference
on an important
aspect of gender.
We do so because a
multidisciplinary approach
is exactly the way to
study gender, an issue that
is both enormously
complex and also
at the heart of
human experience.
We have a wonderfully diverse
array of human experience
here with us today, not
just on the program,
but also in the audience.
As you sit here in
the Knafel Center,
you are surrounded by inventors,
journalists, social workers,
investment bankers, speech
therapists, physicists,
and many activists.
You include the
students and faculty
from across the Harvard campus,
from all around the Boston
region, and from universities
further afield like Yale,
the University of Santa
Clara, and the University
of Oslo in Norway.
Viewers worldwide are also
watching today's conference
through live streaming
on our website.
And in the months ahead,
viewers around the globe
will be able to watch
the video online.
Whether you are here in person
or whether you are joining us
virtually, you are in
for an exciting program.
I want to take a moment to thank
John Huth, today's conference
organizer and faculty
co-director of the science
program here at Radcliffe.
He has worked incredibly
hard putting this conference
together and he did so with
the help of Radcliffe staff,
especially Rebecca
Wassarman and her team,
as well as many Harvard faculty,
departments, and centers
across the university.
I am grateful to all of them and
to our speakers and panelists
for the expertise they bring to
today's exploration of gender
and language.
The theme of gender
and language makes
something of a departure
from many of the topics
that our gender conferences
have tackled in the past.
In recent years, we've explored
gender and the public's health,
gender and migration,
gender and violence,
and women and democracy,
and perhaps some of you
have been here for those events.
These are all topics with
obvious public policy
relevance.
In contrast, today's conference,
which focuses on language
as a fluid reflection
of cultural practices,
might at first seem
to be more abstract.
But the truth is that
we are surrounded
by questions of gender
and language all the time.
Right now, for example, a
writer in our fellowship program
is working on a novel
with a transgender person
as one of the
central characters.
And as we look
ahead to next year,
Jennifer Finney Boylan,
author and advocate
for transgender rights,
will be delivering
a lecture in February.
And this is not just
happening at Radcliffe.
Everywhere we look
lately, we see
the language of gender
identity, the implications
of gendered language
for data analysis,
and the role of gendered
language in public discourse.
Let me share just a few
recent examples with you.
When David Bowie, a popular
music superstar over five
decades, died in January,
Salon.com ran a eulogy
with a headline that read "A
bold, knowing, charismatic
creature neither
male nor female."
In the same month, Alicia
Garza, co-founder of Black Lives
Matter movement criticized
President Barack Obama's State
of the Union for its
failure to address,
and these are
Garza's words, and I
quote, "the needs of black
cisgender and transgender women
and black immigrant women."
Just yesterday, a headline
in the Harvard Crimson
that I noticed read "Gender
Neutral Bathroom Defaced."
Meanwhile, women's colleges
across the United States
are reassessing their
admissions policies
to take into account
transgender applicants.
Facebook, the popular
social media network,
now offers its users 50 gender
self-identification categories.
And both the New York
Times and the Boston Globe
recently ran feature
articles on the search
for gender neutral pronouns
in the English language,
a search that turns out
to have been going on
for a very long time.
Geoffrey Chaucer and Jane
Austen, just to mention two,
both racked their
literary brains
for gender neutral
alternatives to "he" and "she."
In fact, the American
Dialect Society
has just named the
word "they," when
used as a gender neutral
singular pronoun,
as its Word of
the Year for 2015.
And I could go on, but I
think you get the point.
The relationship between
gender and language
is so ubiquitous that
it can become a bit
like the air, something that is
so constantly present that we
never really stop to notice it
because we rarely think about
it in any sustained
or purposeful way.
So today, we will stop to focus
on the interplay between gender
and language at this
precise moment in time.
Our aim today is more
descriptive than prescriptive.
We strive to question
and to understand.
And to help us, we have
an impressive group
of panelists and
speakers, and John Huth
will provide us with a fuller
overview to all of them
in just a moment.
As I mentioned earlier,
John is faculty co-director
of our science program.
He is a walking definition
of interdisciplinarity.
Besides being a
physicist, he has
expertise in planetary
science, cognitive psychology,
neuroscience, anthropology,
history, languages,
and track and field.
He is also the
author, most recently,
of a book about navigation
called The Lost Art of Finding
Our Way.
And I'm sure that under
John's expert direction,
we will all find our way
today to a stimulating day.
Thank you, John.
[APPLAUSE]
-Thanks, Liz.
Oh, boy.
After that, hope I
can make it work.
Well, welcome to the
Radcliffe Institute.
And I'm glad to see
such a great turnout
and hope to get some great
questions and panelists.
We have a really
good lineup today.
So let me begin by
answering the question
that I've gotten
a number of times
with respect to this conference.
How can an experimental
particle physicist
in the physics department
at Harvard University
host a conference
or how did I come
to host a conference
on language and gender?
Because it seems like
a bit of a stretch.
So let me explain.
First of all, the
partial answer is
Radcliffe really pushes
me a lot and it's
been a learning experience.
But there are two stories that
created this, in some sense.
So the first was I was a
minority male in a majority
female meeting at Radcliffe and
I noticed the discourse, which
I couldn't really get into
because I couldn't figure out
the rules.
And so somebody would speak.
Somebody else, the
next person, would
reflect what the
other person said
and then go into their thoughts.
After that meeting, I went to
a physics department meeting,
which was majority male.
And the men would just
interrupt each other constantly
and the few women
in the audience
couldn't get a word in edgewise.
And there was no
reflection whatsoever.
So that was very striking.
In fact, it was something
that I had learned
about as an abstract
concept in the 1970s,
but I'd never really
thought about it.
And here I was presented
with a living realization
in two meetings of this
dynamic that I'd heard about.
The other was a few months later
at my church, the United Parish
of Auburndale, we had a
transgender minister come
and give a sermon,
but the sermon
was really about the
challenges that he
faced basically transitioning,
coming out, discrimination,
poverty, all sorts of issues.
And then we had a panel
of transgender people
who would talk about
their experiences
and just amplified
what the minister said.
But what emerged
in that discussion
was the importance of
language to these people.
I mean, for example,
just the pronouns
that are used for you
can either be helpful
or they can be almost an
attack on your person.
And these two things
coupled together
made me, for the next year,
hyper-alert to the language
of gender, and I was constantly
seeking out more information
and noticing that
things were in flux.
In a lot of cases, I make
the mistaken assumption
that when I enter a
culture or an institution,
that things are dynamic.
But really, over time, I find
that things are changing.
And so what I was
really seeing was
that there was some
segment of language
and the language of
gender that was changing.
Now, the study of language
and gender is not new.
In fact, at least as far back
as 1665, it was written about.
There was a writer,
Charles de Rochefort,
who wrote about a language
in the Lesser Antilles
where the people, if you
as an outsider just entered
and listened to what was
going on, it seemed like women
and men were speaking
entirely different languages.
This was 1665.
More recently, the studies
of gender and language
emerged in the 1960s
where, for example, it
was observed that women tend to
lead linguistic change rather
than men.
So if you really want to find
what's the rules of language,
you go to an elder
male in that society
because they're the last
ones to change their language
habits, which it's true.
Feminists such as
linguist Robin Lakoff
studied this in the 70s, Penny
Eckert into the 80s, and so on.
So the question is, what's new?
What can we learn now?
Because languages are in flux.
In fact, the flux, the
changes, the mutation rate,
is so predictable that if
you take a proto-language
and then you take and
separate two groups of people
geographically, you can study
the languages after some length
of time and by knowing
the mutation rate,
you can identify how long
ago the languages separated
from the proto-language just by
understanding the change rate.
Not only that,
but a language may
come in contact with
another language
and absorb some of the terms
from the other language
until it becomes commonplace.
And so sometimes
there are arcs where
a word may be the neutral
word of the borrowed language,
may have a pejorative
connotation
as it gets absorbed,
and then may
get grasped by the people
who it's describing.
So rather than to
examine language
as a purely academic
concept, what
I wanted to do for
this conference
was to turn the tables
and use language
as a kind of lens or mirror with
which we can look at culture
and use the changes in
language as a way of examining
the changes in culture.
So it's basically
turning the table
on what you might call a
language or a linguistic study.
So to do that, we're
bringing together
people who, I
would say, would be
on the front lines
of linguistic change,
the practitioners,
the people who
are employing words themselves
in an everyday sense,
studying the changes
in an everyday sense.
So using that theme, we arrived
at the panels and the speakers
that we have before you today.
And I'll work backwards.
So the last part of the
day is public discourse,
where we have people who
are active in politics,
advertising, and in
screenwriting and directing.
And the idea there is
that ostensibly, at least
at a first blush,
you might imagine
that the target audience
would be 50% men, 50% women.
Yet the content that's being
generated is by 95% men.
So you might ask the
question, to what extent
does that reinforce
all sorts of norms that
may not be obvious to people?
And how do advertising
executives, screenwriters,
for example, tackle
this when they're women?
Before that, we have
a session on big data.
The emergence of social
networking, social media
can provide both
a tool for people
to use to understand
language usage--
what does that tell us, what
is the experience of people
online based on their gender,
and what kind of new language
might emerge?
Last night, Robin Young
actually recapitulated a problem
that I had with the
term "LOL" in texting.
Like me, she thought
it meant Lots of Love.
And so it led to odd
texts like, "Boy, you're
going up against a big
challenge this morning.
I wish the best for you.
Good luck.
LOL."
And so I actually
committed that mistake
myself, which is a good
example that you'd better
know the usage of a term
before you start throwing it
out trying to be hip.
And our morning session
is entitled Beyond Binary.
And we have Janet
Mock, who will be
speaking as a keynote
interviewed by Moya Bailey.
So what we're trying
to explore here
is how the emergence, to a
greater public awareness,
of trans issues has created,
in some sense, a language
challenge-- for example,
the usage of pronouns.
But even more than that, it's
a question that a lot of people
are not wanting to be
identified by a specific binary.
So what we'll hear, I
think, about the concept
of passing and whether
or not that's even
a good concept at all.
I'll notice that
dictionaries, for example,
capture what you might call
the old male sense of what
words are viable in a language.
So I'll note that the Oxford
English Dictionary in 2003
entered "transgender" as a
word and "cisgender" in 2013
as a word.
So already, there is some
sense of change as captured
by the OED.
In terms of "they"
as a singular,
it's also a generational marker.
I note that my daughters
use it all the time.
When I talk with friends
of my generation,
they will immediately
correct me.
On the other hand,
I've slipped into this.
When I've been writing
in books and papers,
I sometimes use
"they" unconsciously.
I didn't even realize
that I was doing it.
But in fact, I did use
"they" and I got corrected.
So we'll be exploring the
issue of gender binary
and the question of how people
would like to be identified
and how language can be
used in a positive fashion.
One woman last night was
talking about the desire
to raise her child in
a gender neutral home
and, more recently, in a
pangender home, so the sense
that the child can pick and
choose gender attributes
in this different way.
So what I'd like to do
is invite the panel up.
So we have Rebecca
Bigler, Wesley Thomas,
and Bear Bergman.
And to moderate the panel,
we have Stephanie Burt.
So can you come up?
And while you're
taking the stage,
I'll just close with
one, I guess, anecdote.
Last night, thinking
about this panel,
I went into my Facebook page and
went to the little identifiers.
And I chose my gender
to be "cismale"
and I also chose my
pronoun to be "they."
So when my birthday
comes up in two weeks,
people are going to see, "John
Huth's birthday is today.
Wish them a happy birthday."
So-- [LAUGHTER]
No.
You can go up and check.
OK.
So you can see that
I'm in dynamic change.
OK.
So the moderator
for today's panel
is Stephanie Burt, who is
a professor of English.
-Hi.
Yeah.
-And a poet--
-Yep.
---writes poetry, but
also writes about poetry.
And I just wanted to share
the title of one book that
stood out to me, which was Close
Calls with Nonsense-- Reading
New Poetry.
So I have to pick that up.
So Stephanie?
-It's waiting for you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
OK.
Thank you all for coming.
I believe it's my job
to introduce and, what
do we say, contextualize
our panelists who
we're so lucky to have
had travel to be here.
And we will have
about 15 minutes
of each of our panelists
speaking, Rebecca Bigler
and Wesley Thomas
and Bear Bergman.
And are we going to
go in that order, or--
-Yeah.
-OK.
Great.
We'll then have
20 minutes of talk
among ourselves, as it were, and
then 20 minutes or so of time
for your questions.
Is that right?
Yeah.
I have been asked to
introduce and contextualize.
What's your pronoun?
That question was
unusual, except maybe
in an introductory language
class, 10 or 12 years ago.
And now it's something
that a lot of us
hear frequently or
regularly, especially
if we identify as trans
or are under a certain age
or are teachers.
Notice "or" not "and."
Some of us even have two names.
And thank you, by the way.
I'm Stephanie today.
Both names and all
the pronouns you
can think of that are
for people are correct.
I'm going to continue to be
both, but I am Stephanie today.
And that, again,
is something that I
can say to this crowd of lots of
people-- thank you for coming--
and it will sort of make sense.
And you've probably heard
it from other people
in other places.
These are indications
that language is changing
and society is changing,
and each kind of change
helps drive the other.
And things are changing
not just for people
with unusual
relationships to gender,
but for everyone, as
a result. And things
are changing audibly and
legibly as well as visibly.
Things are changing
not only around
conversational and
informal language,
but around legal
language, the language
that government
institutions use to regulate
or attempt not to regulate us.
Things are changing
for works of art.
Things are changing in
terms of what is possible
and what has to be
explained and what
the baseline of assumptions
possible for a set of readers
is for essayists and memoirists
like Bear Bergman, who
I'm so happy to have here.
Hi.
Things are changing for
memoirists of many other kinds.
Things are changing for poets.
In 2013, Troubling the Line,
which is a terrific book
that you should check out
if you read modern poetry,
appeared from Nightboat Books.
It is the first, and it's
a very big, anthology
of trans and gender queer
poets and writings on poetry.
And I'm sure there will be more.
Things are changing
for comic books.
One of my favorite current comic
books is Jem and the Holograms.
If you saw the movie, I'm sorry.
If you watched the TV show
growing up, good for you.
Whether or not you did
either of those things,
you might want to check
out this comic, which
is very interested in visual as
well as legible representations
of different ways, in
particular, of being a woman
and of being a girl.
One of the artists,
the artist who
has the most to do with a look
of the comic, Sophie Campbell,
who is out as a translady.
And in the current issue, number
12, of the current plot-line,
one of the supporting
characters comes out as trans.
They're also doing
amazing things
with other kind of
inclusive language
and with girls' and
women's body shapes.
And we should do something
about comics here,
gender in the visual.
Maybe that's for 2018, but
one more partly verbal medium
in which you can really
see language change just
over the past few years.
And it's changing in
terms of the language
that we use with children
and about children
as well as the language we use
with our college age students,
or if we are college age--
traditional college age,
I should say-- or 30
or 40 or 50 or 85.
I have two awesome children.
And when I meet people
and they discover
that I have two awesome
children, I'm often asked,
is each one a girl or a boy?
And they're 5 and 10
and we're pretty sure.
But when they were infants,
I was always tempted first
to say, why is that the first
question you're asking me;
I wish it were not,
and then to say,
well, we think
that we have a boy,
but of course we won't know for
sure until they're two or three
and can tell us.
I think that's actually the
right answer, of course.
We'll know when they're or two
or three and they'll tell us.
Probability suggests
that they're boys.
And in fact, I have two boys.
And why would that not
be the right answer?
Why would you not say that
every time you were asked?
Why would that answer
make cisgender parents
and non-parents
uncomfortable, if it does?
Why is that still the first
question that parents get
asked?
Why?
I hope we'll get to answer
some of those questions today.
And I hope you see how
the answers are changing,
but how far we still have to go
and how many questions we still
don't know the answers to.
And I also hope today
that we are going to see,
and this is some place where
audience participation can
really help, how not just what
social [INAUDIBLE] you use
and what year it is,
who your friends are,
and how old you
are affects the way
that language and gender
shape your sense of yourself
and of others, but also
how other actual languages
can make the answers to
all those questions super
different.
I don't read Persian,
although I do
read some poetry in
translation from Persian,
and I know people
who read Persian.
And it's my understanding
that pronouns in Persian
do not have genders at all.
Any Persian speakers?
Yeah?
Is that right?
-Yeah.
-That is right?
Thank you.
OK.
When I am speaking
English, I have
to tell people whether I prefer
"he" or "she" on a given day,
and the answer is
usually both are fine.
I'm "she" today.
Hi.
But if we were all
speaking Persian,
this just wouldn't arise and we
could use that energy worrying
about something else.
I think that would
be really cool.
I want to learn Persian.
-Yeah, but then a lot of us
would be out of jobs, so--
-Well, I feel like
you'd be fine.
[LAUGHTER]
Your range as a writer
extends far beyond that.
But that's just one example.
My understanding
is that we're going
to be hearing from
Wesley Thomas about some
of the ways in which different
kinds of gendered language
happen in Navajo or Dine.
Did I pronounce that correctly?
-Yes.
-Dine.
Yeah.
We will be hearing more
about gender and expectations
and how children use
language from Rebecca Bigler.
And we will be hearing-- I'm not
sure what we're going to hear,
but it's going to be great,
from one of the many topics
having to do with gender and
embodiment and sociability
and prose style-- Bear Bergman's
prose style is so amazing.
Please go read Bear's
essays-- and parenthood.
The new book is called
blood-- I'm going to get one
of the nouns wrong--
blood, glitter, wine--
-Blood, Marriage,
Wine, and Glitter.
-Marriage, wine, and glitter.
Marriage is the only
abstract noun in there
so my memory was creating a
cluster of concrete nouns--
and the relation
between the book
before that, which has the
most focused essays on gender
and language and trans stuff
that's not about parenthood,
is called The Nearest
Exit May Be Behind You,
from Arsenal Pulp Press.
I recommend both of those books.
And we're going to be hearing a
lot more about what's abstract
and what's concrete and how
language works from our three
panelists.
And I invite you to
listen to them all
[APPLAUSE]
-I'm Rebecca Bigler.
I'm delighted to be here
and open our session.
The title of my talk is Gendered
Language and Sexist Thought.
I want to just start by
briefly acknowledging
two important collaborators
in my life academics,
Campbell Leaper at
UC-Santa Cruz and Lynn
Liben at the Pennsylvania
State University.
I take full responsibility
for my remarks today,
but I want to acknowledge their
contributions to my thought
and work.
So hypotheses about the relation
between language on one hand
and thought on the other
date back centuries.
Although many mysteries
remain, psychological science
has discovered much about
how the two are connected.
The relation between
language and thought
is reciprocally causal.
Each shapes the
other in ways that
are consequential
for human behavior.
My primary interest
today is in the principle
of linguistic
relativity often known
as the Sapir-Whorf hypothesis,
which states that language
shapes the ways that
people perceive and think
about the world.
Words refer to concepts and
having a word for something
affects how one thinks
about the world.
In my talk, I will summarize
new and striking evidence
that the mere use of words
to denote or mark gender,
referred to as
gendered language,
facilitates gender bias.
In other words, my thesis
will be that gendered language
causes sexist thought.
Languages across the
world vary in the extent
to which they mark gender and
the ways in which they do so.
For the purposes of my talk, I
am going to focus on English.
The English language includes
many means of marking gender,
including honorific titles,
occupational titles, pronouns.
Two points about gendered
language are important.
First, words that denote gender
in English use a binary system.
There are two
dichotomist markings
for gender, male and female.
There is no
linguistic convention
in English for
marking individuals
who fall outside of or between
the categories male and female.
Second, it is typically,
but not always, possible
to use gender neutral
nouns to label people
and thus, speakers
and writers can
opt or not to specify someone's
gender in a statement.
There are obviously
some contexts
in which it's pertinent
to mark individuals'
gender, for example,
when discussing
some medical conditions
that are sex linked
or discussing gender
discrimination.
In the vast majority
of instances,
however, individuals' gender
is marked unnecessarily,
as when teachers
greet their students,
"Good morning, boys
and girls" instead
of "Good morning, students"
or a parent informs a spouse,
"I'll pick up the
girls from school"
rather than, "I'll pick
up the kids from school."
Unlike nouns, however, English
singular third person pronouns
require the marking of gender.
As a consequence, it is
nearly impossible in English
to write or talk about
other individuals
without indicating their
gender and simultaneously
forcing them into the
category male or female.
So what, one might ask?
One possible response is
that gendered language
reifies a gender
binary view and thus
does not allow for
individuals who
have identities that fall
between or outside of male
or female.
Indeed, some individuals have
identities outside the gender
binary and this,
I would argue, is
sufficient grounds for
calling for language reform.
It is not, however,
the only basis
to call for language reform.
Although the routine use of
gender labeling via nouns
and pronouns has been a long
accepted practice in English
in the United States,
there is mounting evidence
of harmful consequences
associated with the practice,
especially among children.
Empirical evidence suggests that
rather than being innocuous,
gendered language profoundly
affects children's gender
stereotyping and prejudice.
It does so via the
processes of categorization
and conceptualization.
It is now well established
that language affects
children's categorization
of both inanimate objects
and animate beings.
In the words of
Roger Brown, "Words
serve as invitations to
form categories" and infants
and young children readily
accept such invitations.
The clearest
demonstration of the power
of labels to induce
categorization
comes, perhaps, from
the systematic research
of Sandra Waxman.
Waxman and her
colleagues have shown
that infants between
three months of age
and two years of age
respond differently
to the identical
stimuli as a function of
whether or not they
are given a noun label.
For example, Booth and Waxman
presented 14-month-old infants
with small models of familiar
stimuli such as cars or horses.
Some infants heard the objects
labeled with the same noun,
whereas others were presented
with the same objects
with no labels.
On test trials,
infants were more
likely to select a familiar
than a novel category object
if they had been
exposed to labels only.
In later work, the authors
extended the paradigm
to novel stimuli,
eliminating the possibility
that the words were
merely calling to mind
already formed categories.
For example, infants who
heard novel objects labeled
with the same noun were
more likely to respond
to the perceptual
commonalities among the objects
than infants who
did not hear labels.
Categorization, in turn, affects
conceptualization of stimuli.
Categorization leads
children to make inferences
about category members.
For example, categorization
induces essentialist reasoning.
Essentialist reasoning is
defined as the tendency
to believe that category members
share natures or essences that
make them what they are.
Susan Gelman and
her colleagues have
generated an impressive
array of evidence
that category
labels lead children
to infer that the
members of a category
share inherent, deep,
meaningful commonalities, even
in the absence of perceptual
or conceptual similarities.
Consistent with this
notion, preschool children
readily make gender
stereotypic inferences
about unfamiliar children on
the basis of their gender noun
labels and gendered first names.
Thus, children raised in the
presence of pervasive gender
noun labels are
likely to categorize
others they encounter by gender
and assume that same gender
individuals are
similar to each other
in many and important ways.
Given that essentialist thought
characterizes children's views
of social categories, the
learning of gender categories
is likely to promote
stereotyping.
Indeed, categorization has long
been considered a key process
in the development of all
social stereotypes and biases.
In 2006, Lynn Liben and I
published a theoretical account
of the formation of social
stereotypes and prejudices
in children titled
"Developmental Intergroup
Theory."
We noted that humans vary
along myriad dimensions which
offer children bases for
classification including
height, hair color, handedness,
whether your earlobes are
attached or not,
gender, race, etc.
We argued that
children look to cues
from adults about which
attributes should serve
as a basis for classification.
Gendered language
is a powerful cue.
It leads children to
categorize themselves
and others on that basis.
As a consequence of
such categorisation,
children, as I noted, endorsed
gender essentialist views
and attend to and
learn the attributes
that are linked with gender
in their environment.
As a result, children
as young as age three
rigidly endorse stereotypes
about occupations, activities,
traits, and other attributes.
In addition to
affecting children's
gender-related cognitions,
gendered language
appears to affect children's
affect, their interests,
and their behavior.
As noted earlier, the
psychological salience
of gender induced
by labels leads
children to categorize
themselves into gender in-group
and gender out-groups,
triggering strong preferences
for same gender peers.
For example, children who
have acquired an understanding
of the words "boy" and "girl"
spend more time playing
with same gender
peers than do children
without such knowledge.
Furthermore, experimental
manipulations
of the degree to which gender
is labeled, for example,
by preschool teachers
in a classroom
shows causal effects on those
preschoolers' peer relations,
with children showing
declines in play
with cross-gender peers when
their preschool teachers label
gender, as in, "Good
morning, boys and girls."
Many additional studies
show that gendered labeling
affects children and
adults' personal preferences
and behavior.
Finally, additional
evidence for the role
of category labeling in
producing stereotypes
and prejudice comes from
studies of novel categories.
In my own long line of
25 years of research,
I place children in novel
social groups, often
red and blue groups, and
manipulate the characteristics
of the environment over as
many as two months of school.
What I find in our line
of work is that when
teachers label the novel groups
saying, "Good morning, reds
and blues" and, "Blues,
line up" and, "Let's have
a blue bulletin board and
a red bulletin board,"
children become biased on the
basis of group membership.
When, on the other
hand, teachers
ignore those group differences,
even though they're
highly perceptually
salient, children
do not develop biases at all.
To sum up, consistent
with the principle
of linguistic relativity,
gendered language
has been shown to
influence individuals'
gender-related cognitions,
affect, and behavior.
Specifically, the use
of gendered language
appears to cause children
to attend to gender,
categorize themselves
and others by gender,
and believe that the
members of gender
share deep, meaningful,
important similarities.
In addition, the
use of gender labels
leads children to construct and
learn stereotypes about gender
and show in-group favoritism.
OK.
Because the use
of gendered labels
appears to precipitate a
cascading sequence of gender
salience, categorization,
stereotyping, and prejudice,
some individuals have
called for the elimination
of the routine and
non-purposeful use of gender
labels.
Teachers, for
example, could refrain
from using gender
to label children
and organize their classrooms.
Imagine, for example, that a
teacher greeted his students
with the phrase, "Good
morning, blacks and Latinos.
Let's have the white
children get their pencils.
Could we sit white, Latino,
white, Latino today?"
That, in fact, violates federal
law, and for good reason.
I would like to see similar
laws prohibit the use of gender
to routinely label
and organize children
in educational settings.
I'm looking for a lawyer
who wants to do that.
[LAUGHTER]
Consistent with this
idea, US colleges
have instituted policies, some
that minimize gender labeling
and classification,
including the creation
of all-gender dorms and
all-gender bathrooms.
Oberlin College, for example,
my alma mater, uses an E system.
Bathrooms are marked with
a default E for Everyone,
but that E can be
rotated to temporarily
make it W for Women and
M for Men. [LAUGHTER]
This solution, like
others, including this one,
are insufficient in my view,
however, because they continue
to make gender
salient to children
and use gender as a
basis for classification.
My ideal marking of bathrooms
would be something like this.
[LAUGHTER]
Although it is
possible for speakers
to avoid gendered
nouns, this is not
possible with English pronouns.
The absence of gender
neutral pronouns
is problematic for many reasons,
but among them is the work
that I just described.
Empirical evidence suggests that
gendered language causes sexist
thought.
To address this problem,
an increasing number
of speakers and
writers are using
new gender neutral pronouns
such as "ze" and "hir,"
just one of several
possible conventions.
Indeed, in the last year, I
have come to refer to myself
and request that
others refer to me
using gender neutral pronouns.
The request derives
from my conviction
that altering linguistic
input to youth, including
the elimination of
routine gender labeling
and the introduction of
gender neutral pronouns,
is an essential
component of efforts
to prevent gender stereotyping
and prejudice in children.
Indeed, I would argue
that it is a necessary,
albeit not sufficient, component
of preventing and reducing
stereotyping in children.
It is my hope and belief
that freeing children
from proscriptive and
prescriptive labels and beliefs
about gender will lead them to
lead happier, more fulfilling,
and more productive lives.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
-Thank you so much.
We're going to hear from
everybody individually
before we have an exchange.
Wesley Thomas?
-[SPEAKING NAVAJO]
Good morning.
When we greet and
address an audience,
we generally go beyond who
is visually in our visions.
We greet to the
middle of the universe
and to the middle of the
earth, to all points.
We sing greetings to all
living things in between when
we use our language.
And our language is
considered powerful.
We construct our
reality with our words.
So it's really shunned
on if you insult somebody
because you're
literally telling them
where to go, for an example, and
there's repercussion to that.
And so language and
words are very important.
What you're saying
is what you really
mean because you took the time
to conjure up that thought.
So thought and enacting it,
you present it in speech.
And there, you
construct the reality
of what's going to happen,
what's going to take place,
and how you greet
people outside of you.
One of the works that I've
been doing for quite a while,
probably similar to
Rebecca, about 25, 30 years,
one point when I got
into graduate school,
I had to go back
to, I guess, called
ground zero to look at the
evolution of our creation
stories.
We have creation stories that
provide us the guidance of how
to live your life.
So it all goes back
to the creation story.
If there's a question, we always
go back to the creation story
because that's the
ones that establish
all the rules of how to live.
In that, also, is
gender identity.
How did gender evolve?
And I had to go back
to the creation story.
And in that, I was
not a medicine person.
Within the many tribes
through the United States,
there are very few
and selected people
who serve as medicine people
with their particular tribes.
By the way, there's
about 557 tribes
in the United States recognized
by the federal government.
An additional 300-plus
is not recognized
by the federal government
because they either
had a very low number or
they lost their language.
So language becoming
a very critical part
in Native communities,
that you actually
have to speak it to
not be eliminated
as a federal government
in the United States.
So there's about 150 that
are in that gray area.
Out of that 557, I would
estimate probably 120 of them
still have access
to the language.
Of those, that particular
group, about 25% of them
have direct connection
to the language,
but not necessarily
speak it fluently.
I'd say probably less
than 10 of the tribes
in the United States are
fluent in the language
and you still hear
that in their homes.
So it's a very, very
small percentage.
So language plays a huge role
in maintaining their status
under the US government.
So in my work, I was
very curious about gender
because when I was
about five years old,
my father-- we'd go to one
of the winter ceremonies.
And these men and women are
dancing outside in the winter
and it's snowing.
And he said, you need to
watch that because, as I said,
when you grow up, you have to
dance in that particular dance
that they're doing.
And I was very
curious as to, why me?
What about my cousins?
What about my neighbors?
How come they can't do that?
And he basically told me
'cause you're born into it.
That is part of your individual
heritage, that you do that.
And in those dances,
there's obviously,
men dancing, males dancing.
There's a representation
of female.
And these were not females.
These were men dressed
in women's clothing,
and very feminine.
And I just had a
passing and seeing that
and then I've never
really thought
about it until later
on why is they're
representing the women in it?
And in my own studies, I was
looking at religion worldwide
and I've noticed that most
of them are male dominated.
Just look at the Vatican.
In our own tribe, women cannot
be part of the ceremonies
because women have natural
power which supersedes man-made
ceremonies, man-made religion.
Women have natural powers
through their menstruation.
So in a lot of
writings, they would
say that women are isolated
or that it's considered bad
or-- women were isolated
in tribal communities
because of the natural
power they possess.
They would undo ceremonies.
So there was a big
separation there.
And in that are what are
called now the third gender,
are people who are born as
male, but switched or clearly
define their feminine
side and evolve and live
the life of girls and
emerge into womanhood
and live their lives as women.
So these are the ones
I call third gender.
And we also have female
children, female babies,
who function in the
role of boys and men.
Those are the fourth gender.
I had to create distinctly
those four to make
sense of what was going on.
And this is all from a
traditional Navajo perspective.
This is something that
is obviously there
through their eyes.
And we're not even entertaining
a Western construct.
And that's coming
later in my work.
In this, I was looking at,
why do traditional people view
this as a third gender?
And my work also began looking
at some of the works being done
by anthropologists,
sociologists,
about the continuum of culture.
My grandmother, my
great-grandmother,
all of those
people, are-- today,
I would consider them
traditional people.
My mother, she has access
to all of modern technology.
She understands English,
but doesn't speak it.
And so I'd classify her
as being a transitional.
She is in the transition
in having access
to a lot of things from
the Western culture.
And I can't fit into
those two categories.
Because traditionals don't
leave the reservation.
They're monolingual.
They're completely rooted into
the traditional ceremonies.
And the transitionals are
a little bit flexible,
meaning they can
leave the reservation
and feel comfortable
outside for a while,
but they're quite
insistent in the afternoon,
they need to return
to the reservation.
They need to go home.
They're really reluctant to
spend a night away from home
because home is essential.
It's important.
Everything there is important.
I'm in a contemporary category.
That's the third one.
My Western education yanked
me into that category.
And being bilingual
in the language
and bicultural, live in
both of them, one at a time,
not at the same time,
I think that creates
a lot of confusion where you
try to live both of them.
And then the fourth
category I've come up with
is-- I call them acculturated.
They're in the process
of being acculturated
into mainstream America.
And then the last one, the
fifth one, assimilated.
They've completely assimilated.
This is just one particular
tribe, that's my tribe.
The Navajo name is a name
given to us by the Spaniards.
We don't mostly call ourselves--
if you really ask somebody
on the reservation what tribe
are you, they would say Dine.
I'm Dine-- I'm of the people.
"Navajo" is a colonial term.
Then we generally don't go and
say oh, I'm American Indian
or I'm Native American
or Indigenous.
Those are just lumping
people together.
In this identity issue,
some of my students--
when I was teaching
at Indiana University,
it was a really a good
example of my students.
They would say, are
you American Indian?
I would say yes because that
means there's less to explain.
If I say I'm Dine, they
have no concept with it.
Then I have to go into this long
spiel of explaining to them.
So you have to pick and choose.
So in a way, I think that's
called a situational identity.
We have that one
[? quite ?] there.
In that continuum, one
gender I focused on
was the third gender.
In Navajo, that's called
Natlee, N-A-T-L-E-E.
If you look at that up there,
besides, you see "self."
To the left of it,
it says "Natlee."
There's a high tone marker
over the A. That's Natlee.
It basically means, in
Navajo language or Dine
language, that one who's in
a constant state of change.
You don't know when
the change began.
it's going to end
or is it ever going to end.
It's in that constant
state of change.
That's the third gender.
And this particular talk is from
one of the more recent writings
that I'm doing.
It's called "Development
and Evolution of Dine Third
Gender," information from that.
I was looking at we now have the
more modernized third gender.
The Natlee was the
traditional third gender,
but the TGs, transgenders, are
reinventing themselves, are
rehashing some of
the terminologies
that we had in the language
and beginning to use that.
That's one of the
same reasons why
on a broader scale in North
America and South America,
we're going to need to use to
utilize the term two-spirit.
Two-spirit is-- how
did that get created?
In the '50s,
there's a major push
to put Native
childrens in school.
So they were taken to
boarding schools, some of them
literally kidnapped from
whatever they were doing
and put in boarding schools.
Then there are those
who are voluntarily
leaving the reservation in the
1960s because of the mandate
that all children need to be
in schools and some of them
didn't want to or some of them
prefer not to be in school.
So people who would have
lived a life of Natlee
within my reservation--
and each of the tribes
in the United States
have their own term
for third and fourth gender.
There's some more work that
was done by Will Roscoe
in collecting terminology.
Like, for example,
the tribe south of us
is the Zuni Pueblo, the third
gender there is called Lhamana.
There's some major writings done
by Will Roscoe which is called
We'wha came to Washington,
DC and went to the ball there
and assumed she was a real woman
until later on, they found out.
And she did some
exhibition there.
And she fell into the
third gender category.
Because gender supersedes
your sexual identity.
What you do as a
man or a woman is
more important than
your biological makeup.
Because your mind
and your spirit,
the mental aspect
of you, is more
important than biologically
of what you're made of
and traditional
categories, that they
see-- if you are
comfortable as a girl,
there was permission
within tribes, especially
tribes that were matrilineal,
that the women were
the heads of household, that
the whole tribe was operating
under the women's
rules, then patrilineal.
Patrilineal, there was
a lot of confrontation.
So there's very few
third and fourth gender
in the patrilineal
tribal societies.
These were warring
tribes of the past.
I was just in San
Francisco two weeks ago.
They had a big gathering of--
it's called the International
Two-Spirit Powwow.
So it's a lot of
dancing, powwow dancing,
cross dressing powwows.
There was Miss
International Two-Spirit,
who was from
Shoshone-Bannock of Idaho.
And I think the ceremony
takes place in Canada.
I'm not sure where.
But people like that.
That was really fascinating to
see people in transition who
are just having their bodies
changed, breast removals, that
were seen as men with
what do you call those?
[NON-ENGLISH] It'll come to me.
The English word
will come pretty soon
so we'll wait for it.
[LAUGHTER]
That's one of the other things
that's really a huge issue,
is this whole
translation thing, trying
to explain things while
thinking in Navajo
and speaking in English.
And a lot of things
that we do now,
we really depend on writing.
Because I was looking at
our language to see why
are this present generation
not speaking the language?
Why are Native people
living on the reservation,
hearing the language and having
direct access to the language,
but not speak it?
So I took a handful of students
and made them my Guinea pigs
for a whole semester and just
talked to them, one on one
and as a group, with
no text, no writing.
The major problem was
they could not remember.
Their memorization skills
have completely escaped.
And I think that's really been
harmed by that with writing,
because every time
we hear something,
we don't let it go up.
We let it come through
our hands and take a note.
And we become
dependent on writing.
It's a crutch for us.
That's why we don't
remember things.
If you have a conversation
with your grandmother
or great-grandmother,
they remember
things and dates and
times when things
happen because they had
their memory skills,
and not necessarily
today's people.
So there's really a lot
more to look into and talk
about Navajo third gender.
And this is not even dabbling
with current terminology
of gay/lesbian.
Those are Western identity.
Those are not traditional
Native identities.
We don't necessarily
identify with that.
So for an example, when
I'm on the reservation
and dancing the wintertime
in women's clothing,
I'm considered Natlee.
And then when I'm in
Native communities,
I'm considered two-spirit.
I don't identify myself as that.
People have labeled
me with that.
And then when I'm off the
reservation, flying here,
being in Boston, I'd
probably label as being gay.
So that's your perception of
who I am, and it's not who I am.
So it just depends.
I have to react to
my location and make
it a little
comfortable for people
around me and for myself.
And then when I change
audience, like when
I go back to the
reservation, then it's
a totally different one.
-Thank you.
I hope we'll get--
-[INAUDIBLE].
-There's so much more I
hope we can get back to
during the question period.
I want to be sure that all three
of our speakers have the time
that we need.
Bear?
-I was at that powwow, too.
That's so funny.
I was just there two weeks ago.
-Mm-hmm.
-Good morning.
-Oh, I love that.
Thank you very much.
Really, I'm a storyteller
and not an academic.
And when I say "good morning"
at academic conferences
and everyone looks
at me like, I always
feel a little uncomfortable.
I'm so excited about
everything that I've already
heard that I just really want to
spend my time talking about all
of it, but I'm going to do the
other thing instead and get
to that later.
In the fall of 1993, I
got into my first argument
with a university professor
about the validity
of gender nonspecific pronouns.
It was the first
of what would prove
to be many such arguments
in the fullness of time.
Freshly emboldened by the smarty
pantses with whom I spent hour
upon hour chatting on
the proto internet,
I explained to my professor
that, in actual fact,
there was nothing
grammatically incorrect at all
about the use of
these tiny words.
I smugly recited
stanzas of Chaucer
to prove the pedigree
of the word "hir"
and then I held my head up and
praised the activists of Usenet
who had invented the
word "ze" to go with it.
Finally, I offered up
my cloth-bound Rutledge
imprinted copy of Gender
Outlaw by Kate Bornstein,
[APPLAUSE] sprinkled with
gender nonspecific pronouns
that I hoped to validate
by their obviously
serious serif type, and my
identity right along with them.
My professor, a second
wave lesbian feminist
in linen separates,
shook her head slowly.
You know who I mean, right?
[LAUGHTER] Those
are not words, she
said and, wrinkling her
nose in evident distaste,
followed her pronouncement
with another one,
and that is not a woman.
Two things struck
me in the exchange
and they continued to
reverberate for decades.
One, that this professor
arrogated to herself the right
to decide whether a
word was real or not.
And two, that she
obviously felt this power
extended to my gender identity
and that of many other people.
The rejection of the word
stood in for the rejection
of the concept, and
me in particular.
Now, while I enjoy a little bit
of dictionary fetishism as much
as the next writer, her
pronouncement and the judgment
it contained were obviously
not about the words themselves,
but about her disapproval
of the idea and, indeed,
the people they described,
underlined by her choice
to disdain both the words with
which Bornstein made it clear
that "ze" did not consider
herself a woman and also hir
[? gendered ?]
[? presentation-- ?] grandly
Goth-infused, high femme
situation we've all come
to love.
People who experience themselves
as neither men nor women
or some combination thereof?
Absolutely not, she said.
And she put her sensible
Dansko clog down
firmly on the subject.
22 years later, the
Oxford English Dictionary
announced that it had included
gender nonspecific pronouns
and honorifics, including
the singular "they"
to their volumes.
And when I finished happy
dancing around the kitchen,
I indulged at
length in a fantasy
in which I could buy,
carefully highlight, and then
mail several hundred volumes
to university professors
around the world, marking the
page with an engraved card
reading only "neener,
neener, neener." [LAUGHTER]
For two decades, I campaigned
on behalf of the words "ze"
and "hir" with varying
degrees of success.
I used them as my
personal pronouns
and I insisted that
people use them
for me in professional contexts,
which meant negotiating that
whoever introduced my talk had
to read them out loud in front
of other people and then I
had to listen to the speaker
make a tremendous performance
about how uncomfortable
those words were
in their mouths.
I pressed newspaper and
periodical writers and editors
to use them in articles about
me with even less success.
I wrote entire books using
gender nonspecific pronouns.
And after going ten
rounds with my publisher
that yes, they really
were real words
and I really did have
the right to use them,
fully half the reviews
my books received
acknowledged that I
preferred "invented" pronouns
or "neologisms"
and then proceeded
to ignore them and use either
a masculine or feminine pronoun
set for me.
I was never able to determine
how they chose which.
I think someone in a back
office was just flipping a coin.
Their choice was recently
unpleasantly echoed
in a stunningly
dismissive New York Times
article about Sasha Fleischman
of Oakland, California,
a genderqueer
identified teenager
who was set on fire
while riding a city bus.
Evidently not content to
let the physical violence
stand on its own, the
Gray Lady perpetrated
its own linguistic violence with
the following parenthetical.
"Telling Sasha's story also
poses a linguistic challenge
because English doesn't
offer a ready-made way
to talk about
people who identify
as neither male or female.
Sasha prefers 'they,' 'it,'
or the invented gender neutral
pronouns 'ze.' The New York
Times does not use these terms
to refer to individuals."
-Yet.
-Let that sink in.
-Yeah.
Yeah.
-In her book
Epistemic Injustice,
British philosopher
Miranda Fricker
describes two particular
kinds of oppression related
to knowledge and language.
One, she terms "testimonial
injustice," which she describes
as the occasion
upon which prejudice
causes a person to
be perceived as less
credible or non-credible in
their capacity as an informant.
The other is
"hermeneutical injustice,"
where a person has no way
to describe their experience
because the conceptual
frame doesn't yet
exist due to their stigmatized
or disempowered identity.
And when I read her
book, I actually
yelped in recognition
of the experience
so robustly described.
And making matters
worse, by the way,
it's not just the suspender
professors and copyeditors
of the world who have fought
me on every instance of gender
nonspecific pronouns.
There are plenty of
transgender identified
people who rail
against the non-binary
with just as much vigor.
Their conviction, frequently
offered at some volume,
is that the idea of
non-binary gender
cheapens and distracts
from their experience,
that it's all right to move
from the known and identified
category of man to the known
and identified category of woman
or vice versa, but not to say
that the categories are flawed,
optional, or even discussable.
Though these people may
have trans identities
or trans medical histories,
their relationship to gender
is heteronormative and binary.
There are two choices,
world without end, amen.
And this too, I would argue,
is a matter of language
as much as it is
of anything else.
In Fricker's
parlance, trans people
suffer a hermeneutical
injustice and non-binary people
suffer it doubly.
The cultural
imagination about anyone
who is not normatively gendered,
trans bodies, identities,
relationships, sex, geography,
conflict, priorities,
is substantially influenced
by what we can write and talk
about intelligibly.
Since the modern conversation
about gender identity
is so heavily medicalized, with
brief and chilling digressions
into legal
terminology, so too are
most of the words that
we have for ourselves
and each other,
medical or legal legacy
words designed to
reinforce the normal
and shine the cold light
of inquiry on the other.
We have no playful language,
no admiring language,
no nuanced language, and
no affirming language.
Instead, we're stuck with
obviously false dichotomies
like "pre-op" and "post-op,"
which have led the entirety
of cisgender humanity
into the beliefs that A,
all transgender experience
is defined in relationship
to surgical procedures that
have existed for about 75 years,
even though trans people have
existed for millennia and I can
prove that, and B, that there's
some sort of single opportunity
trans medical intervention
somewhat akin to the television
show Pimp My Ride where we
enter looking one way and emerge
entirely different and perhaps
with some things chromed.
[LAUGHTER]
What's more, the
process of moving away
from medicalized
language, which is
full of terrible
assumptions and worse ideas,
but has the virtue of being
somewhat familiar even
to people who are
distant from the topic,
is messy and contested.
There is no trans equivalent
of the Academie francaise
where a group of
people meet, discuss,
and decide which new
words are actually words
and what they might mean.
This leads to internal
conflict and heated debate
among trans and
non-binary people
about what words
are best to use.
And because those debates
are entirely decentralized,
unless you count
Tumblr, you could well
find yourself using a word
that you learned in Chicago
as respectful only to be
told in Atlanta that you're
using oppressive
language and get out.
As an educator, I spend a
lot of time explaining this,
that trans communities
have just now come
to a place where we have the
cultural agency, finally,
to explain and describe
our own experience using
our own language,
and that while this
is a messy and
inconsistent process,
it's also a pivotal,
and frankly thrilling,
moment in identity development.
I have some sympathy for
well-meaning non-trans people
who desperately want
to get the lingo
right as an act of ally-ship,
but it's too important
and too exciting to rush.
If we're going to eventually
be able to describe
the specific, delicious,
nuanced particulars
of our non-normative bodies
and experiences and identities,
it's going to take some time.
This is true even though the
larger cultural imagination,
with its limited and limiting
understanding of trans
and non-binary
experiences, can't
fathom what we might be
taking our time about
or why it could be so important.
Most people, especially
the able-bodied,
have rarely or never
had the experience
of having a bodily
experience for which they
have no word or no word
that they can stand to use.
The frequent
exception to this rule
turns out to be masturbation.
The mental blank spot first
gets filled with a placeholder,
like "this" or "that,"
and then maybe it
evolves to a shorthand
codeword akin to a private joke
with oneself or like the kind
of idiolects that married people
inevitably develop over time.
But eventually,
sometimes the moment
arrives in which we hear
a word for the very thing
and we see ourselves
reflected in it.
As a non-binary
identified person,
this was also my experience of
gender nonspecific pronouns.
The jolt of understanding,
the dawning clarity
of why I had shifted with
discomfort when people
used feminine pronouns about
me, but had no special desire
to run into the warm embrace
of masculine language,
all but reset my
skeleton in my skin.
Certainly, it shuffled
the deck of my locution
and dealt me a hand I had
never previously understood
to be a winner.
Where non-binary
identities are concerned,
the hermeneutical
injustice that applied
to transpeople 20-odd
years ago still
rages even though
trans identities
have seen some progress.
For non-binary identified or,
to use my current favorite term,
NB people, this is
magnified by the fact
that while most of
everyone, except Germaine
Greer and Donald Trump,
are prepared to recognize
that transpeople do
indeed exist these days,
the NB population is
still struggling up
the hill with our
glitter in one hand
and our neckties in the other.
These days, I deploy
the word "NB,"
which is just a pronunciation of
the initials NB for non-binary,
with casual authority.
I neither explain nor
describe it unless asked.
My part in the evolution of
language around NB topics
and identities is
that I no longer
engage in the kind of debates I
used to about whether something
is or is not a word.
I know better now.
Of course it's a
word, I tell them,
just like "laser" and
"radar" are words,
just like we used to fax
things and now we Google them.
I try not to even
mansplain about it.
[LAUGHTER]
But I'm wise to the
tactic now, this thing
of pretending to have some
kind of high-minded linguistic
objection to a new concept or
idea being expressed in order
to conceal a prejudice.
I've experienced enough
epistemic injustice
to name it and
stand up for myself
and people like me as
a legitimate expert
in my own identity.
With the cultural power
I have concentrated
as a public intellectual,
a cultural worker,
and let us not forget,
now, a white guy, I
have become stalwart
in my assertions
that people are and
can be trusted to be,
in the words of educator
J. Wallace Skelton,
experts on themselves.
The smokescreen of being
challenged about words
has given way.
And it develops that people
are much more hesitant
about saying, I think your
identity is invalid because it
challenges my beliefs
about the world
than they ever were about
saying, that's not a real word.
Go figure.
I just need two more minutes.
-Yeah.
-This becomes especially
clear when an NB person uses
the singular "they"
pronoun and suddenly, there
emerge strenuous
objections to it
from people who consistently
misuse "lie" for "lay"
and whose entire previous
commitment to grammar
expired sometime around
the end of sentence
diagramming in grade 10.
It would be funnier
if it weren't
so exhausting and demoralizing.
In the 22 years between when
I started agitating on behalf
of gender nonspecific pronouns
and when the OED joined
the English language already
in progress about gender
nonspecific pronouns, anointing
them, along with the gender
nonspecific honorific
"Mx" and the word
"cisgender," there has certainly
been some progress in language.
The cisgender imagination,
especially that of gatekeepers
of law, medicine, and language
whose imprimatur so many
things have previously
required, is expanding,
and with it must
go the language.
Even the word "cisgender,"
a word created and deployed
by trans and NB
people, now takes
a fairly unchallenged place in
academia, at least, though it
apparently upsets a
certain subset of people
whose gender privilege is
so entrenched that they fuss
and kick at being
named with a word
that they didn't coin or
choose, to whom I say, welcome.
[LAUGHTER]
-Yeah.
-I begin to wonder, at this
point, what will happen next.
Will the reality
of our lives become
so present and incontrovertible
on the landscape of gender
that refusal to use
our words will become
the last refuge of the bigot?
Will there be a backlash
against identity politics
that causes cis people
to insist that they don't
see gender and
therefore have no need
to grapple with it anymore?
How will we form systems, forms,
data, and codexes of language
to capture the nuances
of gender identity,
and what new points
of linguistic friction
will each of those solutions
inevitably produce?
Even for cisgender folks,
this is an exciting time.
My friend Scott
Turner Schofield who
used to be a performance artist
and is now a soap opera actor,
which he claims is a lateral
move if ever there was one,
tells a story I
have long enjoyed--
I got it-- tells
a story I've long
enjoyed about needing a
particular tool while traveling
in Costa Rica.
He had no idea what it
was called in Spanish
and so he went to the
hardware store intending
to browse the available items
and choose the thing he needed.
But when he arrived,
he discovered
that the store was more or
less a kiosk and all the tools
were kept in the back
so a shopper was forced
to ask for the thing
they wanted and wait
for it to be fetched back.
Scott, stumped by
this turn of events,
produced in his limited
Spanish the following request
[SPEAKING SPANISH].
"I need the tool with the head
that's shaped like a church."
After some puzzlement,
the clerk laughed
and nodded and came back
with what he needed,
a Phillips head screwdriver.
This is exactly,
in so many ways,
where we find the
language of trans
and non-binary identities.
Without knowing a word for
what we need, we approximate
based on what we think
a conversation partner,
reader, lover, doctor,
or government official
might be familiar
with while we stand
and wait wearing our most
cheerful and polite smiles
and hope that the person will
find themselves willing to do
the extra work to understand.
In the hopeful future,
maybe the words
of nuanced
descriptive and tender
gendered language will be real
in our mouths and on our pages.
But for now, we have to rely
on good will and creativity
to get the job done.
The good news is many of
us have a lot of both.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
-Thank you so much.
Thank you for listening.
Thank you to all three
of our panelists.
And I think we're going
to go to maybe 12 or 13,
instead of 15,
minutes for our talk
because I know a lot of you
have a lot of questions.
There we go.
For my first question, I
wanted to hear Rebecca talk
about this.
And I had two questions.
You can answer one
or both, I guess.
So the first is obviously, this
audience and other audiences
within linguistics
and social linguistics
seems to have been hospitable
to your discoveries and those
that you cite, but how do
preschool teachers react?
Have you gone to the
National Association
for Early Childhood
Education, also known
as NAECTE-- if you have
preschool age children,
you may have heard of
it-- or other groups that
actually train teachers of
young children and said,
here's what you do, here's
what you've got to stop doing?
And how has that been?
And the other question
is, what's the endgame?
In a just world, in the
world that you want to see,
would you expect, based on
your own and others' research,
groups of 5-year-olds,
8-year-olds, 12-year-olds who
simply ignore the history
of self-identification that
has some relation to
biological difference?
Or would you expect gender
to be present in their play
and their language,
but differently?
What's the end game?
-Yeah.
Wonderful questions.
And I do, indeed, do outreach
to teachers, the lay public.
It's a huge part of
my identity and what
I think academics have
an obligation to do.
What I usually find
is that teachers
are very surprised that their
language affects children.
So they mostly say, for
example, well, yes, I say,
"Good morning, boys or
girls" and "What a cute girl"
or "Let's sit boy,
girl, boy girl."
But I don't do it
to be sexist and I'm
pretty sure I'm not making
children endorse gender
stereotypes when I do that.
They're just not aware of the
link between their language
and children's responses.
And I will just briefly say my
worst moment was with an older
teacher, many years
of experience,
who every morning, she had the
children count how many girls
were present and put
up girl paper dolls
and count how many boys were
present and put up a boy.
And I said that that
would contribute
to stereotyping in the
classroom and boys saying,
we're better than
girls and girls--
and she said well, God
made them boys and girls
and I'm going to
label them that way
if I want to, to
which I said, yeah,
well, God made them
black and white
and you don't label that label
in that way, do you, which
led to me being just ostracized
and it was a terrible moment
with the school.
But I do find them
receptive to education.
And particularly, pointing
out the parallels to race
has been affective
about routine labeling.
Now, I want to get
to the end game
because I don't
think the answer is
to become what we have
done often with race,
to be race blind or
to be gender blind.
That is, I'm not arguing
that we should never
talk about gender or race
or other social categories.
In fact, the opposite.
I believe we have to
start having conversations
with even young children
about social categories,
what they mean, and
what they don't mean.
-Yeah.
-The problem is children
have some real cognitive
limitations.
They are rigid classifiers.
They make things very black and
white-- good, bad; boy, girl;
mommies and daddies.
And so once you
create the category
and they build and construct
their own stereotypes,
you're up against a big
wall, a lot of work.
And I think this just means
that we have to, in schools,
start having conversations
with children about gender,
why it's a category, why
it's sometimes relevant,
when it's not relevant, and
what gender stereotyping
and prejudice mean as
early as kindergarten.
-Yeah.
Yeah.
OK.
I have to follow up in one
way because it's something
I've seen as a parent.
It seems to me, and
this is something
that I see as a parent with
my kids and other kids,
it is obviously OK and
we want to encourage it
if a child feels
like it for someone
who thinks he's a
boy to do girl things
and dress up like a girl,
and of course vice versa.
And of course, some kids
feel like neither or both.
And even if you
think you're a boy,
you can wear dresses and do
girl things and that's great.
And we've had a lot of
support from the teachers
who we've been lucky
enough to experience.
But why is it not OK, in
a lot of circumstances,
for white kids to pretend
to be Chinese or Apache?
Why is that not cool?
Do you get that with the very
salient comparison to race?
And how do you answer that to
a six-year-old or to a teacher?
-Yeah.
Again, great
complicated questions,
which require
conversations with children
about social categories and
what they mean and don't mean.
I will say that in
the lessons we do,
I develop lessons
about sexism that we
do with kids from kindergarten
through fifth grade.
And one of the
lessons is there's
no such thing as a boy's blank.
There's no such thing
as a girl's backpack,
shoes, hat, haircut, anything.
And so part of the
lesson is saying
you don't say it's OK for
boys to do girls things.
It's saying there's no
such thing as a girl thing.
There are just things and
anybody can do anything.
But then you explain the idea
that some people do believe
the "silly" idea that
there are girls' things,
and here's what to say.
We teach children to
chant, "I disagree.
Sexism is silly to me."
-Aww.
-And they chant
that to each other.
But then again, the
social categories
vary in their history
and their treatment.
And what requires is
constant education,
then, about what is
offensive about white people
doing things that are
traditionally associated
with African American culture
or, as is common on campuses,
seeing students pretending
to be blind for the day
while they try to learn about
the experience of people
who are visually impaired.
-Yeah.
Thank you.
So I was hoping, Wesley,
if you wanted to--
and I understand that this
may be one of the things
where the right answer
would take too long,
but if the right
answer can be given,
if you could talk
more either about
the differences among Native
American language groups
and cultures in terms of third
genders and fourth genders--
you mentioned that
patrilineal language groups
and societies had much
less robust third gender
and fourth gender
than matrilineal--
or, if you prefer, the concept
of sexuality, of categorizing
yourself by who you're into
rather than who you are,
whether that has any
kind of parallels
in any of the First Peoples
language groups that you /
-In doing my research work using
my own language and my own home
community, one
aspect of it, I was
looking at the third gender
in a traditional setting.
By the way, the
traditional way of life
probably ended around 1930.
Because by 1937, the
last living person
who I would have
identified as third gender,
she died in February of 1937.
And since then, there's been
sheltering and shielding
children within the
families because they've
begun being ostracized
through the various Christian
organizations that were saving
the Indians on reservations
and of receiving a Western
education saying that doesn't
meet the Western standards.
So those people, some of them
were actually literally killed
because of that.
In my work in looking
at the relationship
of the third gender,
for an example,
it's a hetero gender,
meaning that the gender was
a priority over their
sexual identity,
and that between
the four genders
back then-- the first gender is
a woman because she reproduces.
The second gender is a
man who is a husband.
Then the third
gender is basically
biologically male
function as a woman,
so that's a third gender.
So Gender identity
there was feminine.
And the fourth one is
a masculine gender.
The relationship is between,
for an example, a first gender,
is a woman, with
a fourth gender.
First gender is feminine;
fourth gender is masculine.
And the same thing with the men.
The second gender would
have a relationship
with the third gender.
So it's opposite genders there,
even though biologically,
they're the same.
So that's one thing that
came out of this one.
That was very normal,
I think, in a majority
of the tribes in the
United States and Canada
because you hear stories
of where in larger warring
nations, they would
have a wife and they
would acquire a second wife.
And by that time, they
have a few children
and they need somebody
who can provide
some economic stability.
So they would marry a third
wife who was a third gender.
Third gender is
attributed with wealth,
that they're the only
ones in most of the tribes
where they could
accumulate wealth.
If you were not in the third
gender category or fourth
gender category, so if you
were the first or second one,
you cannot accumulate wealth.
That's equivalent to greed.
When you acquire that,
you had to distribute that
to your siblings and to
their offsprings and even
your own children.
You do not acquire that.
So third gender
and fourth gender
were the ones who could
be able to do that.
And so they became second,
third, fourth spouses
to provide an
economic stability.
In one case, I know of
a man who was married,
had a second wife who
was a third gender,
and the first wife died.
The third gender there
in that relationship
picked up the responsibility
of raising the children.
And that's one of the
things that we generally
don't have in our language
is a word for "he" or "she."
We just use gender terms,
a gender-based term
in relationships,
like with children.
[NAVAJO] is generally a
boy or [NAVAJO] is a girl.
[NAVAJO] is a group of girls.
[NAVAJO] is-- no. [NAVAJO]
is a group of girls.
[NAVAJO] is a group of boys.
And terms like [NAVAJO] "There's
an old man coming toward us."
So it's a very gender based
language that we have.
So there's really no
term describing his,
hers, she, he, those
kind of terminologies.
And I've always been
curious about that.
But linguistic is
something that I mostly
stumbled into after parading
through cultural anthropology
for 30 years.
-OK.
-And now I'm heading up
the Navajo language program
and just got an NSF grant and I
have to tackle that to look at.
Generating verbs-- it's a
verb-based, like [NAVAJO] is
more important, like [NAVAJO].
It always ends with verb,
with a verb at the end.
It's not the same as English
where there's a subject,
then there's a
verb and an object.
In our language, it's
subject, object, and verb.
-OK.
-So the verb is at the end.
-Yeah.
I'm sorry.
I want to be sure
that we do have
enough time for your questions.
And if you can maybe just
introduce yourself really fast
and ask?
-Yeah.
OK.
Is this on?
Yeah?
-Yeah.
-I'm Lucy Ferriss.
I teach at Trinity College
in Hartford, Connecticut
and I also write for
the Lingua Franca blog
at the Chronicle of
Higher Education.
-Oh, good.
-And as a sort of
default, I seem
to be the person who writes
about gender and language
on that blog.
And if you want to see
something about the readership
of the Chronicle of
Higher Education,
you can go to the
comments that any
of my-- it's basically
descriptive blog posts
about language seem to invoke.
So please come visit me
there and help me out
with some better comments.
[LAUGHTER]
But my question--
I was listening
to the poet Alejandro
Zambra the other day,
who's a Chilean poet.
And in his remarks, he
mentioned how important
it was for him that in
Spanish, objects are gendered.
And as I'm sure
everybody here knows,
in romance languages,
that's quite common,
that everything is gendered.
And of course it's
a binary gender.
I mean, things are either
masculine or feminine.
And he loves that as a poet.
He loves thinking about a table
as being a masculine object
and about a window as
being a feminine object
and using that in his poetry.
And I have no idea if there
are discussions of the kind
that we're having
here among people
who speak other languages
where gender is not
so much about the person
as it is about the world
that the person encounters.
And I wondered if any of you
had any comments on that.
-In my language, we have that.
Hills are feminine.
Rocky Mountains is masculine.
The rain that comes with
thunder is masculine.
The drizzle is feminine.
Smooth the running
water is feminine.
Rushing water, like through
the Grand Canyon, is masculine.
We have plants
that are masculine.
Ideas and thoughts
are genderized.
Ceremonies are genderized.
Behaviors are genderized,
despite being a woman
and you're aggressive and you
go through that masculine stage
and react from that.
Your body, your left side
is masculine your right side
is feminine.
Your biological body
is-- if you're a man,
it's supposedly
supposed to be male.
But the inner side
of you is feminine.
So there's that contrast
throughout the Navajo world.
Smooth river rocks are feminine.
Other rocks, hard ones with
sharp edges, are masculine.
Flowers are like that.
Even dirt is genderized.
-Wow.
If you're not a linguist and you
want to see someone explaining
the research on gendered
nouns in romance languages
and European languages, there's
a book by Guy Deutscher,
D-E-U-T-S-C-H-E-R, which I was
hoping somebody would bring up,
but I think I have to do it,
called Through the Language
Glass, about what forms of the
Sapir-Whorf hypothesis are true
and which ones are false.
And that book, the last
chapter talks about the John
[INAUDIBLE] stuff
about location.
You probably know it.
Yeah.
The second to last chapter
talks about a very, very large
psych department-y
study of gendered nouns
in German and gendered
nouns in French.
And it turns out that if you do
a very good academic psychology
study with people
clicking buttons
to see what their
reaction times are,
that if you speak a
language where a bridge is
a feminine noun, you will
have a slight propensity
to think that
bridges are welcoming
and forgiving and soft.
And if in your language
bridge is a masculine noun,
you'll think of them
as hard and tough.
Not much, but a little.
So there is research on
that in romance languages.
-OK.
Thank you.
-Can I just-- sorry.
I just want to respond
briefly to that,
partly because I really
feel the conflict that
comes in that question.
As a writer and artist, I always
am so interested in the ways
that we use language
very specifically, very
strategically, in order to
make certain kinds of points.
And on the other
hand, whenever anybody
starts talking about gendered
nouns in romance languages,
I can't help but think
about things like in French,
"mustache" is a feminine
noun and "vagina"
is a masculine,
which it possibly
contains a tiny amount of
sexism in addition to the ways
in which it's complicated.
Because when you ask French
linguists about this,
they will say, well, things are
assigned masculine or feminine
not based on their attributes,
but based on how important they
are, they say very proudly.
And so since the
vagina is so important,
we obviously made it masculine.
[LAUGHTER]
-Like like the big
mountains in Dine.
-Like the mountains.
And I just sort
of think, listen,
the cookie you're waiting
for is not coming.
And so there's
always that tension.
Lyricism and
euphonia sort of bang
up against the desire to
not reify certain kinds
of oppression.
I think it's a very
interesting question.
-Hi.
My name's Rachel
[? Hannibutt ?] and I'm
a master's student at
the Harvard Graduate
School of Education right
across the way here.
And I'd like to make
a shameless plug
for a really great at exhibit
about India's third gender,
if anybody wants to check
it out during a break.
But my question, Bear, you
spoke of the gatekeepers
involved in this
work and Rebecca,
about children and
identification.
And in my own work of the
conflation of just the terms
"sex" and "gender"
in academic research
brings out what advice do you
have for young researchers
or really anyone hoping
to change the conversation
in the field of research?
-Read broadly, find a
passion, and follow it.
[LAUGHTER] I will
say in my journey,
I've been surprised
where I ended up.
For example, I didn't start
out studying language.
I was actually,
frankly, very surprised
at the incredibly powerful
role that labeling
played in gender stereotyping.
That was not what I thought.
I thought that teachers had to
say sexist things like, "Boys,
please move the heavy tables
in the classroom; girls,
clean the blackboards."
I thought, when I started,
those kinds of statements
would produce stereotyping
instead of just saying,
"Good morning, boys and girls."
That was as much a surprise
to me as to the teachers.
So my advice is have a
passion, read very broadly
across disciplines, across
areas within disciplines,
and then design the
best studies you
can to address your questions.
-Thank you.
-I would also say be shamelessly
flexible with your language.
One of the things
that happens, I think,
is that we learn a word, we like
it, and then we keep using it.
And sometimes when
language develops,
we're reluctant to join
in the new language
because we feel like, oh, but
I invested so-- for example,
I invested a ton in the idea
of gender neutral, right?
And then eventually, it
really became clear to me
that gender neutrality
was not remotely something
that I was interested
in being involved in,
that gender nonspecific
was actually the word
that I wanted.
And so I had published who knows
how many pages worth of gender
neutral.
And there comes a
certain point at which
I found that I had to
say, all right, I've
learned better, to constantly
be evolving in terms of best
practices in language and
then modeling them and really
standing up for the
language that you feel best
about regardless,
to whatever degree
you can, of other
people's variously
cloaked concerns about it.
-There are all these
people waiting.
I want to get as many questions
as we can in the time we have.
-Hi.
My name's Jen [? Detterick ?]
and I run the Equal Rights
Amendment page on Facebook.
And there's this, I
don't know if you've
heard about it, an election
going on right now.
I don't know if it's been a
big topic of conversation.
One of the candidates is
of a different cisgender
than the other candidates.
Again, I don't know if
you know about this,
but on the Equal
Rights Amendment page,
I posted some pro articles
about this candidate
and was immediately greeted
with, gender doesn't matter.
Why are we talking about
gender on this page?
This is the quality page.
Gender means nothing.
And I would vote
for Elizabeth Warren
so clearly, I'm not a sexist.
And so beyond me having
to say you're not
allowed to mention Elizabeth
Warren until the election's
over on the page, I'm wondering
about how I talk about that.
Because the Equal
Rights Amendment
is there's no
discrimination based
on sex, which is
based on the fact
that historically,
there has been one
presented gender that has
been discriminated against.
So you wonderfully
touched on this,
and you also did, about
we have to, at some point,
discuss gender and we can't say,
I don't see gender and that.
How do we talk about
it in a productive way,
about why it would be important
to bring forth women publicly,
why that matters even when we're
talking about gender not being
an actual real thing
or being a fluid thing?
-Can you just say
because misogyny?
-I could.
I wish.
I wish I could.
#BecauseMisogyny.
-I mean, that's kind of
the answer in my mind.
-Yeah.
-I will jump in and say
I did a study in 2006
of children's understanding
of race and gender
in the presidency.
So we asked whether the
presidents of the United States
have been only men, only
women, or both men and women,
just to see if kids knew.
There hadn't been any
work that even established
whether kids paid attention.
They do.
By kindergarten,
the vast majority
of children in the United
States know that only men
have been president.
And then we asked them why.
Why is that true?
And we discovered that there
were a couple big clumps
of categories.
One third of kids said
it's because girls
are too stupid, too dumb,
too weak, too ignorant
to be president of
the United States.
But about one third said
the boys hate girls.
Boys will never vote for girls.
Boys won't listen to girls.
And therefore,
girls had never been
president of the United States.
This indicates to me that we
need to have conversations
beginning in elementary school
about the links to gender,
to actual roles
like the presidency,
like computer
science and physics,
like men and preschool teaching,
and try to have conversations
with children about why those
links arose in the first place
and why they are maintained
and how they are maintained.
So in other words, the
answer is to have discussions
about sexism with kids beginning
really early in their lives.
-Yeah.
Nice.
You're not on Twitter, but I am.
And it sounds like--
your name is Jen?
-Jen, yeah.
-Yeah, Jen might
want to post links
to those studies on her page.
-Yes.
-If you send me those
studies, I will Tweet them.
-That would be helpful.
Thank you.
-Thank you.
Next questioner.
-OK.
Hi.
My name is Jessica Mink
and I'm an astronomer,
but I'm also really
interested in gender issues.
As a scientist, we
classify things a lot
and categorize things
a lot, and I also
find that just about
everybody does that.
And one of the
things we're talking
about when we talk about
gender now, which is different
and a lot of people don't
understand this yet,
is that we're
decategorizing gender,
that that's a really important
thing to individuals.
And gender's not just
becoming-- I mean,
non-binary means more
than just a third thing.
It means a lot more things.
And that's really
hard to explain
and it's really hard
for me to totally grasp
the totality of that myself.
And I'm trying to explain
a little bit of non-binary
to people who-- non-binary
is a term that's come up
in the last two or three years.
So where do we go?
How do we decategorize gender?
What kind of activities,
actions can we do?
Where do we have to do it?
I mean, we've got to do it to
adults, and that's not easy.
-So the question is, how do
we undo inherited categories
for gender?
The largest question
that's been asked so far.
Wesley, do you want to
start with that based
on analogies to other
languages where the categories
are different?
Can we undo what
goes on in English
by using those contrasts?
-Yes.
The one I just presented earlier
between first, second, third,
and fourth gender
is just in Navajo
language, which I translated
into English for you.
That's just four categories.
There's additional
categories beyond that,
like for an example,
two-spirit is
a category that comes
both in male bodied
or female bodied two-spirit.
And then we introduced
numerous terminology
we have in English
that comes in-- TGs,
TSes, gay, lesbian,
non-identifier, that adds more
into our community.
So in our community, we can't
label everybody saying, oh,
he's gay or lesbian.
We have to ask them, how
do you identify yourself?
And we hear all these different
types of terminologies.
So we're now beginning to look
at multi-gender terminology
in our language.
And what we did is we moved the
Navajo language and use that
to translate the English
identity, that those
are being used.
-Rebecca, Bear, do you
want to answer directly
or should we hear the
other questioners first?
-I'll just jump in
and say, not only are
physicists categorizers,
scientists, but as I presented,
infants are.
Humans are brilliant
categorizers.
They have a predisposition
to categorize.
But they are also incredibly
flexible about which
bases they use.
We are capable of completely
ignoring some potential bases
of categorizing.
As I said, we could
categorize each other
by whether our earlobes are
attached or not, whether we're
right or left handed,
which is biologically based
and has something to do with
our brain organizations.
But most the time, we
totally ignore that,
and children totally ignore it.
So the helpful side is
I do think humans are
born with an incredible
capacity for flexibility
in how they operate, perceive,
and see people in the world.
And so it's our job as adults
to be very thoughtful about how
we construct and give
messages to children
about which bases are important.
-So good morning.
I'm Licia Verde.
I'm an astrophysicist
so I work in
a male dominated environment.
And despite that,
I've never asked
myself question about
language and gender
so this is all new for me.
I sympathize with the
host of this conference,
having found myself at
physics faculty meetings,
and enough said there.
So maybe I'm stating
the obvious here,
or maybe I'm seeing the
elephant in the room.
There are two completely
different issues.
One is find, beyond
male and female gender,
something to define
somebody because somebody
feels that doesn't fit into
any of these two categories.
But that is another
issue, which is
there may be situation
in which gender
should not be an issue at all.
And this should be
two different words
because these are two
completely different ballgames.
So for example, we
say Mr. President
and we say Mr. President
to Mr. President Bush
and to Mr. President Obama.
If Hillary get elected,
would we say Mr. President?
Being president is not
related to the fact
we are male or female, it's
you're good enough for the job.
So there should not
be a gender associated
to that, and with this,
along with being professor,
being CEO, or whatever.
While on the other hand, find a
gender neutral word and putting
everything in there, it's
putting apples and oranges
together.
It's two completely different.
-I'm going to try to
make that into a question
because it seems
really important.
And tell me if I got this wrong.
On the one hand, we ought
to remove gendered language
where it is not salient.
On the other hand, we ought to
accept and develop a language
for talking about
gender where it
is salient that fits the
diversity of lived experience.
How can we do both of those
things simultaneously?
Aren't they mutually
interfering tasks?
Is that the question?
-Thank you.
Great.
Thank you.
-OK.
-I don't think they're mutually
interfering tasks at all.
I think that one of the things
that is really present in both
of those is broadening
the vocabulary that we
have to talk about gender.
Why is it not possible
to-- all right.
Let me back up a step.
I think that it
should be possible,
and it seems like it is, to
have gender nonspecific language
that can be used both when
gender is not a factor
or we are signaling that we
don't want it to be a factor
and for situations when a person
does not identify themselves
with any of the most
common gender categories.
I think that the
interesting piece for me
starts to crop up because as
soon as you make a list of all
the possibilities-- I
was a little bit involved
with the folks who made 51
genders on Facebook or 52
genders on Facebook
or whatever it is.
And as soon as they released
the list and your Facebook
had a dropdown
box of 52 options,
people immediately
started to complain
that their particular
preferred gender wasn't listed.
And that is the thing that
crops up over and over again.
At a certain moment in identity
politics people start to say,
but I prefer to identify myself
as this complicated, 11-word
adjectival phrase, and I
don't see that recognized
in the literature.
And at the same time,
we all, I think,
recognize that there is value
to having some ability to label
ourselves because it gives
us a banner to group under,
for certain topics.
-[INAUDIBLE] Yeah.
-I'll just acknowledge there's
a fundamental value question
at the base of the debate.
I tend to be on the side
of a more gender neutral,
minimize the salience
of gender as a category,
but I totally
recognize there are
people who argue that gender
is incredibly valuable.
I want to say I'm a woman
and I identify as a woman
and I want to have spaces
where there's women.
And then you might
argue well, and we
need 12 different
genders, but we
want to maintain
all these genders
and the focus and the salience.
And I think that's a
fundamental mental debate
that science isn't
necessarily going to solve.
-OK.
Last word?
-I'm not in that
conversation yet.
I'm still in my own
tribal [? mind ?]
of how I'm constructing gender,
but I will be coming to Bear
and get some information
from him about everything
else in the Western culture.
So that's something that's
still not there yet.
-Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]